[Music]
my favorite thing is that dude um
that Airsoft sniper Mustang
what is that yeah kicking Mustang this
is like my fourth time bringing him up
he's just this English guy that plays
[__] he plays Airsoft but
the locations he plays Airsoft in is
crazy and he Snipes the whole time
yeah yeah yeah oh he's over there
cheater yeah he has so much footage of
just nailing guys like four or five
times in the head and they just don't I
hit you in the head yeah see [__] like
that it's fine [__] yeah cheater
bro that that Airsoft bazooka one is so
funny wait let's see it real quick he
actually has a bazooka
we filled this with nerve gas and
uranium so if anyone holy [__]
it's just ammo so he uses this ghillie
suit and it it completely Works he'll
just lay flat and people will walk by
him clueless but I love when he'll walk
up behind someone and he'll just tap
them with the gun he'll be like you're
out and they go oh [__]
he doesn't even shoot him
uh here's the thing when he catches
these guys like supposedly cheating some
of them I could see on the first one
being like
did we did we get hit because he's just
you can't see him these dudes have no
clue yeah he just tagged them both they
have no clue oh yeah okay bazooka time
holy [__] is he allowed to bring that in
no that's what makes it better
why don't we do Cody and Noel do AirSoft
yes you guys I love it man and you guys
take everybody we go to an island right
Island
you drop everybody off you put you and
Cody pull out a briefcase you start
setting up the gun and you go over on
it's a man hunting trip okay so it's
like inverse Battle Royale yeah yeah
yeah yeah you think you could go to war
oh dude I'm dead ASAP
zombies I could do I feel like I could
last war I'll be I'll be dead I'm so
clumsy you saw me [__] spill the
recipe
Walid get that get that Claymore which
one
um it's funny I always ask Zach I was
like what are you doing if like [__]
goes down he goes I'll just kill myself
yo they just yo they just launched it
holy [__] man
see if I if I'm doing Airsoft I want to
do that I want to do [__] 100 versus
100 like oh yeah I want like a tank
field you want like or like a chain gun
rigged up with Airsoft bullets I want it
to feel I want trench warfare I want it
to be scary dude yeah I want to strap
Airsoft Grenades on my chest yo relax
relax
well he's like I want to strap
Airsoft C4
Airsoft Minigun especially if I play
like
I can't show up to the field of this
dude
you'd be pulled over oh dude I remember
I did a Vine or a video or something I
made like a fake makeshift like well it
was like some dumb bit I don't even
remember what it was maybe where it was
like a bomb right yeah took PVC pipe red
construction paper for some wires a
calculator whatever right and I remember
I like put it in my car or something
and I remember I was picking my mom up
at the airport and they were pulling
people over to like look through their
cars and [__] like this one day the day
I go
dude I was [__] freaking the [__] out
I grabbed the thing and I'm just sitting
on it like this like like so
uncomfortable next thing you know I'm
pulled over they're flashing they say
pop up in the trunk all this stuff and
then they're just like all right go but
dude my heart [__] drop it's the
scariest [__] of my life
never never again I report on hard mode
man
that [__] was [__]
never [__] again airport on expert
mode going through TSA with PVC a Nerf
Claymore
what that's actually kind of sick look
at him look at the image yo this image
is so American wow this is so American
dude is there more weird Nerf [__]
because I know Nerf culture is like
Airsoft culture and like
yeah
yeah for nothing the the thing is like
as a kid you see these people make these
crazy Nerf videos where it's like some
guy on a helicopter or the commercials
or whatever yeah and then when you get
it and you play with it as a kid you're
like kind of ass kind of bad yeah
bullet yeah after
what was the craziest Super Soaker you
ever had I don't think I've had a super
soldier oh that was like a thing when I
grew up yeah yeah look up monster Super
Soaker yeah holy not that one go down
the one with the purple tank
there's a stand for it
no no no no scroll down that one purple
tank on the rear this alien dick looking
thing that's sick
I remember
everyone at Super Soakers on the Block
and I conned my parents into getting
this
I it was like I knew as a kid there were
those days subconsciously where my
parents were checked out yeah and that's
when I could ask for stuff I think
everyone had that right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I remember we were in Toys
R Us
and
I just it was just a I could just feel
it my mom did not give a [__] that day
and I'm like can I get this she goes
yeah how much was it at the time
I think look up the retail on this thing
I want to say I remember it being pretty
expensive because the 50 higher she
balled out I want to say it was like a
hundred bucks holy [__] she loves you
average retail was 50 40 bucks for that
one yeah okay so maybe the one I got was
maybe
60 or something yeah riding home with
that thing you're a [__] guy dude I
felt like I was coming home with like
the you know I'm the [__] Cavalry now
yeah yeah when I pulled that [__] [__]
with me everyone's like yo yo yo
a kid's like is that a real gun
why is it an alien dick looking things
up man in Black guns dude
this is what Will Smith used to kill
that giant so did everyone [__]
gasket because that was the thing right
you're like well all the other kids in
my block were like in pretty good
situations with this they were like oh
sick and then they went and got them and
I'm like okay that's cool yeah
but the way this thing uh loaded water
so at the bottom of the pump it had this
like hot plate that you could hook up to
a hose so you could just like
it was nuts man
it was sick
see when does it go too far
probably when there's a bullet in there
what is that a uh for nerves just
airsoft guns let's see a rip let's see a
rip see if this is real life and I had
to run through [__] Warehouse
containers I'd be dead immediately
because you triple yeah I would just
[__] well
he's shooting at some chicken you know
what's also funny about this thing is
painting an orange tip on that does not
tell me that's not a gun okay you're
walking on the street with that [__] in
an orange tip I'm like that guy has a
[__] RPG
[Laughter]
believing that